the legendary game show host Alex Trebek
could soon be saying goodbye to jeopardy
he said I've done I will have done it
for 34 years
that's enough he's tired he's getting on
in years he's 78 years old he can't see
himself necessarily doing it and into
his 80s too Alex Trebek he might be
retiring soon is that the case you guys
won't win jeopardy be right out Alex
Trebek right
Josh is one of these guys that has
always been a little extra Pro I don't
know I'm not surprised that I'm here
today
ken josh mokuba Phil Alex Trebek's shoes
I think the better question is can he
fill his mustache and the answer is yes
I think this is a journey of destiny and
desire and how it comes together and one
little boy's dream of asking answers
they think that's how it works will come
true you're gonna join the Supreme Court
of game show host and if we're gonna get
you there you as in josh mokuba we're
gonna have to do this right and I am
gonna be a fair evaluator and if he does
stink I'm gonna let him know but I know
he's not gonna say he would never stay
never let's get into it here is the
first round of Josh pretty
I think josh is gonna ask us a lot of
questions hopefully about entertainment
things in the news I think the world
wants to know what was it like being at
the Royal Wedding it felt much more
intimate than it did from the outside
how was the food guys expected dancing
was fantastic yeah yeah we all got down
with the Royal we should all be silly
all the cameras were gone we got down
I'm expecting to hopefully not look
foolish to ring in on time and form my
questions or answers in the form of a
question Freddie Lockhart we've been
buddies for a while you're a gameshow
enthusiast a game filled memory in the
80s 1987 I think it was a guy named
Chuck random bored on Jeopardy and I was
like nobody's gonna top him and then
years later what's his name King came
along Ken Jenny Ken Jennings and Topton
and I actually got to meet Ken Jennings
one time I fanboy hard yeah there you go
fan of Jeopardy fan of Jeopardy oh wow
I'm expecting a lot of fun and really
really interesting questions dead humans
called walkers take over the world
led by Robin Williams as an
inspirational English teacher Freddie
what is the Walking Dead Poets Society
[Applause]
I've been training my whole life to be
the next host of Jeopardy since I was 10
years old my mom asked me what I wanted
to be when I grow up I said I wanted to
be Alex Trebek
or a regular at a bar you don't really
have to do much to be a regular at a bar
but you do have to train hard to be the
next Alex Trebek he is sort of announced
his retirement and I feel like today is
my opportunity to prove to Japanese fans
and Alex Trebek the Jeopardy producers
and the general trivia going public that
I have what it takes to be the next host
of Jeopardy
[Music]
I think my buzzers broken try it try it
works
[Applause]
[Music]
what is curling what is curling is
correct for two thousand things I don't
like people who don't use these when
changing lanes give me just a smidge of
Rage Jimena what is it turning
that is correct what does it turn [ __ ]
no she got that money back from The
Daily Double
Bob Marley Freddy what are the Wailers
the Wailers is correct
well done Freddy
today's winner is Janina gavankar thank
you all for walking in the copier i'm
josh mokuba this has been Josh moody
we'll see you next time
[Music]
I mean I tell you man I had a blast it's
everything I dreamed of and more I just
you know give me that chance it was
wonderful
so much fun it was just great it was a
nice experience I had a great time
playing Josh Purdy
it would have been nice to have one but
I choked I did not think I was gonna be
this invested in it and when I won I got
lightheaded I almost passed out I know
it's not jeopardy but it really did feel
like I was running an episode of
Jeopardy and I felt like it went
smoothly everybody had a blast when Josh
was hosting I saw a level of
professionalism which he has but it was
so professional I got nervous I mean
some of the other contestants I think
we're all pretty nervous because it
seems so legit Josh did a great job and
he made it so easy for us I really had
fun Josh was so easy easy breezy I mean
this is this is totally a gig he could
kill I know Josh is the right man for
this job somebody stepping into this
role as the next host of Jeopardy has an
incredible legacy to uphold you can't
change much about the game because it's
pretty much perfect what I would like to
do is just bring in my sort of energy
I'd love for my generation of people my
the Millennials or whatever that they
see jeopardy how I see jeopardy as the
best show on TV a lot of people may
think this is funny or this is a joke or
whatever but I am very serious about
this and but also my own fun way we'll
make this individually Josh Brody